The Joe Rogan Experience hey Derek you
know how I got so jacked oh I followed
the nine ancestral tenants oh that I
heard that worked really well
it's the best way yeah boy when I saw
that video that you posted you actually
sent me the video after I'd already seen
it I I caught it like within three
minutes of you posting it oh my God I
saw it it just showed up on YouTube feed
I'm like oh yes here we go and uh wasn't
surprised at all no I mean it's all it
seems completely makes sense but that's
exactly what I expected yeah it seemed
like just a matter of time for him
there's no way you can look like that in
your 40s that chat I mean he's
preposterously jacked do we have a
[ __ ] now that we know that he's full
of [ __ ] we're talking about the liver
King by the way ladies and gentlemen a
lot of people like what are they saying
this is all inside yeah there's a guy if
you don't know who the liver King is the
guy calls himself the liver King and
he's this guy who uh walks around
everywhere with no shirt on I've seen
him in Vegas with no shirt on big bushy
beard super jacked and he was telling
people that the way he gets that way is
by sunning his balls he uh he he
literally really lays down with his
[ __ ] staring at the sun and eats raw
liver and just lifts like a maniac and
that's how he's so jacked but it's
Preposterous yeah too many polar
extremes to have just like a unique
marketing spin that was just highly
viral in my opinion and I don't know I
think most people could see through it
but at the same time he would like there
was a lot of big names that even reached
out to me after the video came out and
they were like you know I didn't think
he was natural but this guy literally
right to my face would say like
blatantly I am natural and like a lot of
people will take a guy that's word at
his word when it's like a private
conversation and if he's straight up
telling you in person yeah it's actually
legit I'm natural and he was just lying
through his [ __ ] teeth seemingly
there's some people that are really
jacked that are natural for sure some
people that are like super super
disciplined they um you know they're
taking supplements but all legal
supplements that you can get it like a
vitamin store and they're just like
they've never gotten off the grind and
who's that guy Paul sklar did you
comment on him yeah yeah he actually uh
did blood work like immediately after I
had talked about it one time and it
checked out yeah he looks like what's
possible yeah like I If you don't know
who that guy is he's super jacked and
he's 50 years old but and when I'm
looking at him I'm not getting any like
steroidy Vibes I'm getting a really fit
guy who works out really hard and has
probably been doing it for 30 years yeah
that's that's what I get when I look at
that guy that's all feasible and
possible now please go to the liver King
please show me some Preposterous liver
King physiology oh he has uh have you
seen his apology no I haven't I want to
watch it he comes clean on steroids you
I [ __ ] up
I don't know I don't know if you guys
are able to watch these images though I
want to see some images of his body
because his body is just so off the
charts ridiculously massive
yeah yeah I want to I want to show some
of him like jacked and lifting because
he's just [ __ ] gigantic
so he did Cover the ab implants and
etching again he said no to both even in
his apology touches on it is it I mean I
guess it's possible if you're on that
much juice that your ab muscles grow
that big too
because the kind of stuff he does
is you know very core specific like he's
doing a lot of stuff where he's like
cleaning and pressing kettlebells and
walking with them over his head and all
that stuff really does ignite your core
and if he's doing that all the time I'd
imagine it's possible that those are
real ABS but that was the question do
you think those are real abs
um yeah personally I think they're
legitimate ABS and the the etching thing
I think is more of the controversial
topic did he have some sort of like
cosmetic work done to
Target locally in the fat around the
abdominal you know definition would that
make much of a difference though because
he's very lean clearly if you look at
his arms you look at his chest you look
at everything like look at that image
right there he's so lean I mean how much
fat would you even be talking about and
how would that make the the thing is the
topographical map of his his abs the way
they pop up like mountains that's just
Mass yeah that's where the question of
whether or not that's real or whether or
not they're implants that's what I was
leaning to is just like I feel like his
overall body composition is pretty
consistently represented I don't think
he has like this like I get that his
the argument is they don't change in uh
like when he sits down or anything the
density of them and like the separation
is so dramatic that it's got to be
something yeah and you know you could
never really say if it was well done
like what did or didn't happen I don't
think it's implants so that would be
really obvious in my opinion well
granted then it's like well if it's
unnoticeable would you even right you
know right it's like plastic surgery you
only see the stuff that's not good are
you guys able to play the apology
without it being caught sure
yeah we can play it first come after us
I don't know what like the Spotify
copyright oh listen I think Spotify can
handle this okay by the YouTube version
because let's play it put a little bit
up on it yeah if you put it on YouTube
you're more than allowed to here it goes
liver King confession
let's open a terrible sound try again is
it a connection issue Maybe
yeah hmm weird that's happened before
what is that I don't know
a lot of people believed him including
the Bell Brothers Chris and Mark Bell
I'm like wow guys you do steroids how do
you how do you not look at that guy and
go clearly I think Mark likes to think
that a lot of people like he again he
doesn't want to put a
is it working right
like a limitation on what's possible
like he likes to believe that you could
and again because this the problem with
this too is a lot of people will
extrapolate this out and then thank
everyone with a jacked physique must be
doing something which is problematic
because then it sort of creates this
right this narrative around you know
everyone's lying or anyone with a good
physique it's impossible to get there
without yeah doping your [ __ ] face
off kind of thing which is not the case
there are certain individuals who like I
do believe that physique
okay maybe not maybe not that physique
but like within Striking Distance of
that in
0.0001 percent of individuals you could
get there naturally yeah potentially
hyper responders yeah guys who are just
like ridiculous genetics like Ronnie
Coleman natural yes yeah perfect example
yeah Ronnie Coleman natural was super
jacked but he couldn't compete with the
most Jack guys and then he started doing
steroids yeah then he just exploded but
he's super honest about it like when
Ronnie talks about it he just will
explain like up until he was 30 years
old he was natural yeah so can we get it
okay
I've got a little
sounds yeah maybe there's another
version of it I think there's something
wrong with my cable for some reason I'm
looking at the audio on my feed and it's
not is it the cable or is it how it
connects is it like it's one of the
other it's but it could be both that's
an old ass laptop isn't it no it's a new
one oh okay old cable Maybe
yeah it's quiet I don't know something's
wrong that's all right let's play we can
hear what he's saying uh
all right
I'm making this video to apologize
[ __ ] up
because I'm embarrassed and ashamed
because I lied
and I misled a lot of people
I've stated that this is a complicated
as [ __ ] Topic at least to me it is
because before social media I was rich
and Anonymous and after social media I'm
still rich but no longer Anonymous and I
never expected this kind of exposure in
the public eye
it's been tricky as [ __ ] to navigate
well
clearly I did it wrong and I'm here now
to set the record straight
yes I've done steroids and yes I'm on
steroids
hormone clinician uh never came to
public figure was an experiment to
spread the message to bring awareness to
the 4 000 people a day who killed
themselves that 80 000 people a day that
try to kill themselves our people are
hurting at record rates with depression
autoimmune anxiety infertility low
ambition in life
our young men are hurting them both
feeling lost weak and submissive so I
made it my job until I will teach him he
did it for the hurting people come on
Derek the comments are not too favorable
on that part of the video
this is my fight this is why I exist
pause
your highest and most dominant form what
he that he wanted everybody that's
depressed and trying to kill themselves
to reach their highest most dominant
form but he wanted to lie about how he
achieved his physique so mislead these
people they just by eating liver you can
come close to that so as you fail at
that as well as everything else you
failed at life that led you to the point
of doing
something to yourself that you're
thinking about committing suicide yeah
like that's what he's saying I feel like
in this video he had like a very good
opportunity to just straight up say
sorry I [ __ ] up Etc which I think he
thought he was doing but he also makes a
few little comments in there that I feel
like people really dug in on like the
whole I didn't expect it to happen this
or me to blow up this much it's like it
was very meticulously planned out from
inception of the brand within this I
don't know if you saw the emails but
it's like within one one year I want to
be at exactly this in social media
following and this is what I'm gonna do
what's his social media following at now
Jamie which is like uh Instagram
I bet he's at 5 million I think on Tick
Tock 1.7 million on Tick Tock he's at
like three point something million yeah
half of its Chinese Bots
maybe all right let's play some more of
this nonsense yeah it's spreading the
message I've been on several podcasts
and when asked if I'd ever taken
steroids I've always said no I don't
touch this stuff not gonna touch the
stuff never touch the stuff
I've convinced myself that this had
nothing to do with the ancestral message
I convinced myself that I'm not a
competitive athlete of any kind so who
the [ __ ] am I cheating I convinced
myself
that this topic was a placeholder for a
far more important conversation I
convinced myself that this would
overshadow that 36 years of working out
usually twice a day without
that's not true I've convinced myself
that this was the book of minority
usually in the fitness category driving
to an unproductive conversation
and I had convinced myself
that this would be the wrong message to
send to the 15 year old boys oh the 15
year old boys continually dismissed it
the ones who actually can get jacked
it's difficult we've we've seen enough
he's you know what the problem is
sometimes people don't hang out with
people that are smarter than them
and you think you're the smartest person
or maybe because he's running this
company you know people have to listen
to him so he's got this distorted
perception of his ability to communicate
and his ability to like convince people
like that was so theatrical and so corny
I don't know how like what kind of
thought process went into there there
was some sort of Roi calculation on if I
lie like what is the probability I get
outed versus how viral can I go if I lie
from the get-go versus like I just don't
know how his team especially with the
information out there thought that it
was going to be a net win where it's
probably never going to come out does he
have a team I yeah it's pretty elaborate
like his team was uh well he has a media
team that he hired to kind of like right
but they're just employees one of them
came up to me in Vegas oh really yeah
one of my security guards stopped him he
was like I'm a producer for the liver
King I'm like Purdue what the [ __ ] do
you produce what are you producing yeah
I wouldn't be surprised it's not a movie
like how many UFC events did he try and
kind of like cozy he was Frontline front
row at one of my shows in Vegas oh damn
at the MGM yeah and then I saw him again
at the Canelo fight he was trying really
hard to get on the podcast and he's been
trying really hard to get on now he uh
contacted contacted a few friends of
mine and some of them that have like
Bert Kreischer that had him on the show
yeah he told me he's trying to get on
for what what say that more like come on
this is dumb man this is a [ __ ]
uranicon game and you got busted yeah
and it's unfortunate that you feel
terrible I'm sorry you feel bad because
that's just what happens when you get
caught lying but you didn't have to lie
yeah like I don't even see how bad it
would have been from the get-go he was
like I you know it's not the healthy
replacement yeah but like I I understand
the not wanting to talk about the other
[ __ ] because he was on Winstrol deck
yeah high amounts of GH Etc which is not
ancestrally consistent but neither is
HRT because it's like well right if your
diet was so dialed like why is it that
you don't have like adequate testicular
function or adequate hormone output or
this or that and it's just like I guess
it kind of just like spit in the face of
his message too much that he couldn't
wrap his head around justifying yeah
coming out and saying I'm on a chart
seat but do this other stuff